a lot of women in my culture they don't
work they just sort of stay at home and
the man goes out and gets the money and
they just raise the kids obviously we've
moved on from that but I still hold
those values in the sense that I'm okay
to submit to my man when the time is
right or when I feel the time is right
but the whole point is that's that's not
submission is when you feel I mean we're
women we change our opinions every
goddamn day we don't even know what we
want half the time so it's like if you
if I employ blessing and I say blessing
turn this camera angle on or I do do
this do this and at the end of the day I
have a final say and and that's kind of
how it is should be anyways when you're
submitting to a guy so so you're saying
that's what men want they just want
someone to go yes I'll do exactly what
you tell me to do now they just want to
argue all the time with every decision
okay